[Applauso]
di fronte a questa immagine non
rimarrete indifferenti
lo so perché questa è un'immagine di
guerra e ci tira fuori tanti sentimenti
non è solamente la guerra che distrugge
la guerra che crea disastri che crea
ferite e una guerra che porta fuori dei
sentimenti molto molto pesanti
perché ho scelto questo quadro per
parlarvi del mio tema perché vorrei che
vi concentrate proprio su questi
sentimenti che sono non solo la
devastazione ma sono lo sgomento la
disperazione ma anche l'incredulità e la
paura
ecco questo è quello che provano
tantissime donne in una guerra
sotterranea che abbiamo di fianco tutti
i giorni e che io ho scoperto
praticamente quasi per caso
era il 1990
mi sono avvicinata a degli avvocati che
contestavano quella che allora era una
decisione dell'america di attaccare
l'iraq di attaccare i paesi che avevano
il petrolio e eravamo avvocati per la
pace e li abbiamo contestato quel modo
prepotente di dominio che si voleva
imporre non so se qualcuno di voi
ricorda si parlava di una possibile
terza guerra mondiale la guerra del
golfo
in quell'occasione una donna mi ha
avvicinata in un'assemblea in cui
parlavamo di tutte queste cose mi ha
detto ma perché non vieni nella nostra
associazione stiamo costruendo un gruppo
di donne
che si occupino di donne che subiscono
violenza ne ha subito incuriosita sono
andata ho accettato questo invito ed ho
scoperto veramente una guerra
sotterranea una guerra che le donne
raccontavano ma ancora non si conosceva
e non se ne parlava come se ne parla
oggi ma chi erano queste donne erano
tanti tipi di donne
c'era molto pregiudizio si pensava che
fossero solo donne disperate senza mezzi
senza capacità che non avessero studiato
in realtà no mi sono ritrovata
addirittura delle mie colleghe che mi
raccontavano situazioni di violenze che
veramente sembrano sempre incredibili
casalinghe manager libere professioniste
persone di ceto basso di ceto medio di
ceto alto persone con capacità
economiche normalmente si pensa che se
uno ha capacità economiche non arrivi a
certi livelli non è vero abbiamo subito
detto che questa violenza era
trasversale e come mai allora continuava
ad esserci un aforisma mi aiuta che dice
che è più facile entrare in quasi ogni
cosa che uscirne
e proprio vero infatti noi ascoltavamo
tutti quei racconti e dicevamo come
facciamo ad aiutare queste donne perché
possano uscire dalla violenza
affiancandoci a loro e sostenendole
quindi abbiamo cominciato a studiare che
cosa si potesse fare in modo anche
attento competente anche scientifico
tutto però c'è sempre venuto dai
racconti delle donne e il ciclo della
violenza è stato studiato alla fine
degli anni settanta in america le norme
che era una terapista avendo ascoltato
tante donne lo ha costruito lo ha
proprio diciamo portato
perché fosse a conoscenza di tutti come
si possono sviluppare queste storie
e che cos'è il ciclo della violenza ci
racconta come ci si entra in questo
tunnel
e quanto sia difficile uscirne c'è una
prima fase che è quella della crescita
della tensione che quella della
provocazione dove ci sono tanti momenti
molto particolari che tra l'altro ogni
storia fa se c'è la donna che ci
racconta della pasta che non è piaciuta
però qualsiasi pretesto e magari prese
insieme al piatto buttata dentro al
cestino la pasta tirata sulla testa
della donna
tutti i racconti che io ho ascoltato e
uno si domanda ma perché è una donna
rimane dentro questa situazione la prima
domanda che si fa in generale donne beh
io vi vorrei portare qui la voce di una
donna che ho seguito e che è uscita
dalla violenza e che mi piaceva lo
dicesse perché l'ha detto in maniera
molto chiara proprio davanti a un
giudice questo perché perché ero
innamorata di lui e pensavo che potesse
cambiare e altrettanto tipico uno dice
mah strano come mai queste donne stanno
in questa situazione
eppure dobbiamo fare i conti anche col
sentimento e l'altra cosa si passa da
una fase quindi dove cresce la tensione
si fanno delle provocazioni piccoli o
grandi alla fase dove scoppia la
tensione scoppia con un'aggressione ma
attenzione che non è solo un aggressione
fisica può essere anche un aggressione
verbale può essere anche un impaurire
attraverso la rottura di oggetti
attraverso lo sbattimento delle porte
attraverso tutta una serie di atti che
portano a dire qui decido io quello che
si fa e come lo si fa
e allora questa è la fase in cui dallo
smarrimento iniziale si arriva proprio
allo sgomento perché è una persona che
ti vuol bene che sta facendo quella cosa
una persona qui
magari hai affidato tante confidenze un
pezzo della tua vita e quindi se è
sgomento
come reagisce vi voglio portare ancora
la voce di questa donna ho sempre notato
la suddetta speranza che fosse anche
colpa mia ed è comportandomi
diversamente tutto questo non sarebbe
successo
ecco lei dice ho nutrito la speranza che
fosse colpa mia
addirittura questa è una frase che fa
rabbrividire io quando lo sentite l'ho
letta nel processo penale pensavo di
avere sbagliato anche a leggerla in
realtà è proprio così lei spera che sia
così per darsi la possibilità di uscirne
il problema è che non se ne esce perché
cosa succede
c'è la fase della cosiddetta luna di
miele che è quella forse alla fine anche
più pericolosa anche più pericolosa
dell'aggressione perché fa pensare a una
donna che il pentimento e le attenzioni
e amorevoli che in quel momento il
violento porta per riuscire a recuperare
una situazione che fosse sta perdendo di
mano e forse lo faranno cambiare forse
succederà qualcosa per cui non ci sarà
più quella situazione lì non si ripeterà
invece le loro volta ci dice proprio che
questo è un ciclo che va a ripetersi un
tunnel e noi quando intercettiamo le
donne vorremmo che in quella fase
il secondo momento del maltrattamento e
quello della luna di miele decidessero
perché è quello il momento giusto per
poter uscire il momento in cui lo
sgomento si trasforma in paura
ritornano i sentimenti di una guerra e
si può cambiare qualcosa e invece il
ciclo ricomincia
se da lì non se ne esce e si crede a
quel pentimento vorrei farli sentire per
l'ultima volta la voce di questa donna
quello che non capiva come lui
in cui mi insultavano i modi peggiori
[ __ ] stanza parolacce di ogni tipo
quando si calmava voleva avere un
rapporto sessuale con me e io non potevo
dire di no altrimenti serve ed è
cominciato tutto da capo ecco lei aveva
già messo in conto di non potere dire di
no perché altrimenti ricominciava tutto
daccapo la paura la paura che paralizza
una donna che sta dentro questa
situazione è quella che consente al
violento di procedere e di andare avanti
in tutte queste fasi quando si arriva al
maltrattamento quando si riprende il
ciclo il maltrattamento che arriva la
volta successiva lo dico sempre a tutte
le donne che in conto è un
maltrattamento che è sempre più grave e
quindi è importantissimo poter fare il
passo di uscita il prima possibile
e quali sono i numeri della violenza di
genere in italia forse li avrete anche
già sentiti una donna su tre tra i 16 ei
70 anni ha subito violenza e alla fine
l'istat ha calcolato che sono 7 milioni
queste donne di cui 4 milioni e mezzo
hanno subito violenza sessuale è un
milione e più ha subito violenza
sessuale
ancora più grave cioè stupri o tentati
stupri
questa è la situazione dei numeri sono
numeri che non cambiano sono numeri che
si ripetono sono numeri che abbiamo
fatto emergere anche con il lavoro dei
centri antiviolenza ma con il nostro
lavoro abbiamo messo in evidenza anche i
costi perché noi dobbiamo porci anche
questa domanda che cosa succede quando
una donna subisce violenza succedono
tantissime cose
comunque anche all'esterno e quindi
andrà un pronto soccorso vi chiederà un
terapeuta prenderà dei farmaci chiamerà
la polizia forse farà una denuncia la
denuncia sembra che sia quella che
risolva tutto non è detto che questo sia
anzi molto spesso non lo è purtroppo ci
sono tribunali che lavorano
costantemente su questi temi ci sono
tutte le spese legali e le spese dei
servizi sociali e le spese anche dei
centri antiviolenza che fanno la loro
parte e tutti questi costi moltiplicati
per il fattore produttività perché una
donna che subisce violenza non sarà a
livello sociale
la stessa persona non potrà essere
attiva come lo è chi vive serenamente
più o meno la propria vita che risultato
da questa operazione è stata stimata in
26 miliardi di euro e noi riteniamo che
sia anche sottostimata sto parlando
dell'italia non sto parlando del mondo
ovviamente e nel 1217 in italia circa
50mila donne si sono rivolte a un centro
antiviolenza capite che qui i numeri non
tornano
i numeri sono tutti da rivedere e tra
poco vi dirò anche come per coinvolgere
tutti noi in quello che possiamo fare
anche se non lavoriamo in un centro
antiviolenza perché questo perché noi vi
vorremmo anche soprattutto le donne
vedere nel nostro centro anche aiutarci
in tanti modi si può aiutare un centro
antiviolenza ma qui oggi non voglio
chiedervi questo tipo di aiuto né un
aiuto personale né un aiuto economico
dal punto di vista dello stage del
sostenere perché in genere sulla
violenza si fa sempre questo passaggio
quello che vi vorrei chiedere invece è
quello di aiutarci tutti a ridurre
questo numero di donne che devono
rivolgersi ai centri antiviolenza come
direte voi
è qui la situazione la dobbiamo valutare
tutti insieme perché oggi si parla di
cambiamenti
e noi dobbiamo pensare che purtroppo su
questo tema di cambiamento non ce n'è
stato moltissimo perché anche la manager
anche la persona che ha disponibilità
economiche culturali capacità rientra
dentro questa situazione perché è una
questione di relazioni intime
si dice che la violenza sia un rapporto
sia determinata da un rapporto di
dominio tra generi se questo è vero
allora vediamo un attimo perché c'è la
prevenzione che è importante per noi
in che cosa può consiste nella
prevenzione
ma la prevenzione la possiamo fare tutti
cominciando dall educazione
dall'educazione dei nostri figli
io dico sempre ci sono stereotipi che
noi non riusciamo ancora a scalfire al
maschietto si dice non piangere come una
femminuccia
il maschietto lo si scrive a calcio lo
si scrive a rugby e si fanno fare sport
diciamo di una certa forza virulenza
alla femmina si dice non fare
maschiaccio e comportati bene e si
educata si carina soprattutto si è
carina
quando noi facciamo tutto questo tante
femmine poi tantissime ragazzine vanno
danza la danza ormai è tutto il mondo
delle ragazzine
allora quando noi facciamo questi
passaggi rischiamo di avere costruito
una struttura che porta quell'uomo o
quella donna quel futuro uomo quella
futura donna a poter entrare dentro
questo meccanismo perché un meccanismo
dove qualcuno domina e qualcun altro
rimane sotto allora badate sicuramente
qui in questa sala ci saranno persone
che o hanno subito violenza o hanno
agito violenti
e se i numeri e la statistica ce la
raccontano giusta come io credo dovremmo
cominciare a farci delle domande su come
noi ci comportiamo e questa è la prima
cosa scomoda che io vi dico perché se
noi continueremo a comportarci in questo
modo saremmo anche con i 20 con certe
forme di violenza
se noi giriamo la testa ad esempio
rispetto all'amica rispetto alla collega
rispetto al collega che si può
comportare in maniera non scorretta di
più che si può portare in maniera
aggressiva perché tanto una donna si
possono dire tante cose non non reagirà
nello stesso modo in cui potrebbe
reagire un uomo
ecco allora mettiamo le basi per questo
quindi quello che vi chiedo è di
cambiare di cambiare il nostro modo di
pensare
sapendo che le donne stanno dentro quel
ciclo della violenza perché noi a volte
giriamo anche la faccia dall'altra parte
o perché noi abbiamo costruito quel modo
di stare delle donne dentro alle
situazioni e i rapporti di coppia
quindi cambiare le nostre menti per
cambiare le nostre azioni e forse per
essere un po più liberi e felici tutti
grazie